so what do you say to guys that are in
countries with laws like that do you
tell them not to approach or what's your
what's your solution as a dating coach I
mean if they I tell them to move if they
can I mean that's pretty extreme but
like in Australia for instance like they
have a new thing where women can change
their mind about consent during sex
and that's you know I have Australian
clients and and they're just terrified
they don't even want to get in a sexual
situation because there's no one there
to witness that so it's just he said she
said right and they're going to take the
side of the girl in a lot of the cases
I'm not saying that like bad stuff
doesn't happen but it makes guys very
apprehensive same with the Scotland
stuff guys were already afraid to go and
approach it now they don't want to have
legal trouble right so as these
countries and what they're trying to do
is combat harassment of women these are
real problems but when they impose these
very strict kind of lockdown measures
then it turns men away from speaking and
leads to the statistics